après avoir connu un été meurtrier par
manque de moyens et de vaccins la
tunisie est en passe de sortir de sa
quatrième vague de kobe de 19 grâce à
l'aide internationale la campagne de
vaccination s'est accélérée tunis espère
administrés de doses de sérum anti
corrida plus de 50 % de sa population
d'ici l'automne objectif éviter à tout
prix une nouvelle vague épidémique le
point avec notre correspondant à tunis
bassem chez bis
c'est une nouvelle livraison tout droit
venu des états unis qui a été
réceptionné samedi par les autorités
sanitaires tunisiennes près de 500 mille
doses du vaccin fader ont été offertes
par washington dans le cadre de
l'initiative
kovacs une autre livraison de près de
180 à 1412 supplémentaires devraient
arriver aujourd'hui dans le but
d'appuyer les efforts déployés par les
autorités tunisiennes dans la lutte
contre le coc vie des 19 selon les
derniers chiffres publiés dimanche par
le ministère de la santé dix sept
nouveaux décès ont été enregistrés soit
un taux de positivité de 19,85 contre 12
59 la veille une stabilité due à
l'accélération de la campagne vaccinale
dans le pays qui a été possible grâce
aux nombreux dons de sérum réceptionné
durant tout l'été depuis le lancement en
mars dernier de la campagne de
vaccination près de 2 millions 700 mille
tunisiens ont fini leur cycle vaccinale
dans un pays qui compte moins de 12
millions d'habitants
malgré l'amélioration de la situation
des ministères de la santé continue
d'appeler à la vigilance et au respect
des règles sanitaires en vigueur tout en
annonçant une nouvelle journée nationale
de vaccination demain qui sera consacré
aux cadres de l'éducation nationale
objectif pour le gouvernement atteindre
le taux de 50% de vacciner d'ici à la
fin du mois d'octobre depuis le début de
la pandémie le bilan humain s'élève en
tunisie ainsi à près de 24 mille décès
un chiffre important qui rappelle à quel
point les infrastructures sanitaires
peine à être renouvelée dans un pays
touché à la fois par l'inflation et par
une crise de gouvernance